how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talked about everything
Marvel and all things relating to the
MCU
today we're going to be talking about
spider-man 3 and about how Black Panther
just might be in the movie and play a
pretty significant role
now spider-man and Black Panther aren't
usually two people you would group
together but a villain just may unite
the two of them and there also could be
the start and the formation of the Young
Avengers so we'll break down everything
that could happen in this video if
you're new be sure to subscribe to stay
up to date on everything relating to the
MCU and so you can enter this week's
giveaway for a chance to win a
spider-man of 5 from home Funko pop just
subscribe but like the video and leave a
comment down below so right now
although the villain has not been
confirmed for spider-man 3 it's widely
believed to be Kraven the hunter
spider-man is going to be wanted as a
murderer and he's going to be on the run
and Kraven has been rumored and he seems
like the most logical choice to hunt him
down but there's been a rumor going
around that everybody seems to believe
is actually going to happen in the movie
which is that Kraven the hunter is going
to be from Lokhande now there are many
different reasons that Spider Man 3
could tie into Wakanda and Black Panther
which we'll talk about in just a bit but
Kraven the hunter beam from Wakanda is a
big one we know that Peter is going to
need some help in spider-man 3 he's
going to need some type of a mentor and
if the villain the person who is chasing
him and possibly after his life is from
Wakanda it would make perfect sense for
Peter to go to T'Challa because if
somebody like Kraven the hunter is from
Wakanda Black Panther will definitely
know him and that leads us the three
main reasons of how Wakanda should be
connected to spider-man 3 as pointed out
by reddit user marveled Rotch the first
one is that if Kraven the hunter is
going to be from Wakanda he could get
his powers from stealing one of the
heart-shaped herbs this would give him
pretty similar powers to Black Panther
and coincidentally spider-man he would
have superhuman strength agility speed
he'd be able to jump from great
distances he'd basically be just like
Black Panther and if he is from Wakanda
he could possibly have some wakandan
technology as well this combined with
Kraven the hunters tracking abilities
would make him a very formidable foe and
again would make him one that Peter
would most likely need help defeating
which would bring in
like Panther the second reason is that
if Kraven the hunter is from Wakanda and
if he does get his powers from the
heart-shaped herb a battle between him
and black panther would actually make a
lot of sense as they probably have some
sort of a history together and would
make Black Panthers appearance in
spider-man 3 very logical the third
reason which is a very very interesting
thing to think about is that probably at
some point in time either in the
beginning or the middle of the movie
peter is going to need a new Spidey suit
now in spider-man homecoming and
spider-man far from home he had the help
of Tony Stark and he had suits that had
start technology but it is kind of safe
to assume that since he has to run away
from home and run away from New York and
Stark Industries it may be safe to
assume that he won't have access to any
of Starks technology not to mention well
conduct could be a very great place to
hide for Peter
after all the true nature of their city
was unknown to the population for many
many many years since they have the
ability to cloak their entire city so it
would be a great place for Peter to hide
but they also have the technology to
make him an awesome new suit in fact it
could be more advanced than any
spider-man suit that we've ever seen
before but spider-man go into Wakanda
would put him awfully close to Kraven
the hunter but as you can see story wise
that actually makes perfect sense of how
spider-man could include Black Panther
Kraven the hunter and Wakanda but there
is another aspect that could lead to the
formation of the Young Avengers and that
is a friendship between Peter Parker and
shuri based off of everything that we've
heard spider-man is going to go on to
lead the young Avengers but it's safe to
assume that he's not going to be
entirely alone on this journey and
that's we're sure he would come in she
could definitely supply the Young
Avengers with any tech that they may
need and any support that they may need
as well and not to mention as we learned
in Black Panther she's been dying to get
out of Wakanda and experience somewhat
of the normal world and this would give
her the perfect opportunity so just like
Sheree is the tech person for Black
Panther and Wakanda she could go on to
become the tech person for the Young
Avengers so as you can see there are
many different ways that Wakanda and
Black Panther could be in spider-man 3
it makes sense story wise but it also
makes sense as far as the
future of the MCU goes with the Young
Avengers but let me know what you think
about this is this something that you
would like to see in spider-man 3 Black
Panther at Wakanda and Kraven the hunter
being from Wakanda let me know what you
think about this in the comments down
below don't forget to like this video
and subscribe so you can stay up to date
on everything relating to the MCU of
course you can follow me on Twitter for
live updates and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof woof